I feel to see him up there Jordan
there's a there's a sense of pride
there's a sense of like it's almost
mind-boggling yeah because you kind of
go yeah right
and then there's it and I was telling
will this in the hallway
they're always theirs and this is a
character defect of mine there's always
a sense of what the [ __ ] have I been
doing
she's do you mean like he always goes
back to my [ __ ] stupid narcissistic
yeah your ego [ __ ] driven yeah you
know personality of like what the [ __ ]
you've been playing [ __ ] scar stardew
valley 16 hours a day
but what ya good finish it but pissed
off his wife in the video game and now
she's not talking to him no for a full
hour today
no no what happened no there's no
consequences what happened was Haley a
pink cake and hey Liam try to off my
relationship sister she maybe she hasn't
won you it's a farming simulation game
both stardew valley and i've been
playing it for 16 hours a day
okay yeah you won Academy Awards some
day you in the hallway I thought it was
very interesting how Jordan said I
stopped and started writing this
screenplay 20 times I walked away from
it 20 times gone no one's gonna yeah
blah blah blah and you have that same
cross to bear you got to get that wife
in the farm game to start talking to you
again it doesn't matter if it takes 20
times we all have goals right yeah you
know you know just run out of my face
dude
I have addictions oh yeah alright
[ __ ] addictions you know what I went
on Twitter yeah and I saw a lovely
picture oh it was on Instagram of Keegan
giving Jordan a really big hug you so
happy for him and the meme was what the
kids were saying was give me one friend
of my life like keegan-michael key
you know like Jordan has in
keegan-michael key yeah you know what
I'm saying yeah and if and if the key in
key and Peele is happy 4p
I'm [ __ ] happy I'm sorry two guys from
MADtv
can't do [ __ ] why'd you say out in the
hallway you said what have I done with
my life and I said Bobby you still alive
that is what you said there's plenty of
time you know you know what what you
know that was what I just expressed yeah
was just a little thing in my head I
shouldn't have said it out no you should
you should say everything honest 9%
completely [ __ ] proud of the fights
back all right all right now the right
way I gave you a little bit of like
there was a little bit of my hand yeah
out there and what a [ __ ] rape that
idea I mean yeah you know that's not
right either well whatever [ __ ] you know
why kobe bryant won an award yeah he
paid off some chick you know when he
took her into a room and there you go
you know more stringent rules so serial
killers don't get out of [ __ ] prison
Andy what do you think of that yeah you
here's a curry you [ __ ] Canadian fool
I'm agree with you there I even think of
committing a violent crime in Canada
you're going to jail because we all have
the chip it was a Chinese guy who a
Chinese guy who ate the teenager and he
had a boss that guy out but he was
allowed to change his name and his whole
identity yes [ __ ] up but that's Canada
for you yeah so don't come in here and
[ __ ] me to my [ __ ] little thoughts
all right in Canada they let people they
let Chinese be great people
[Laughter]
[Music]